welcome
back
Audrey
um
the other day which means the day before
yesterday
era
Luna yes
where in every other country celebrates
Labor day except for the US yes workers
foreign
So today we're cooking another Dolce in
another dessert Anita
is it let's see so that is
it's like I finished
please
thank you
so we can celebrate by baking
and we will bake kantuchi
so what is
they are called in different ways
sometimes they're called kantuchi
sometimes they're called
Chini
what does the eating mean
and in the U.S there are known good job
you will make variations also with
raisins and with chocolate drops
so that's that's I guess that we call
these things
right
it's Italian and it's it has two teeth
in the US usually you say biscotti
in Italian is any sort of cookies
so for me for example chocolate chip
cookies
yeah
so what does coffee
twice
so they're cooked twice we will cook
them twice
because coffee is cooked twice
this is from Latin it means coffee
foreign
yes
and there are fun to cheat
that are very famous and then there are
also
kantuchi di Siena which are slightly
different and Sienna is another
beautiful city
in induscana and there is a bit of a
competition between ferente and Siena so
I have a very very dear friend from
Siena but I'm sorry tonight
so I hope you want to watch that
but one of the differences is that in
the viscosity the Siena in the country
Sienna
that is
butter butter
and while Scotty
there is nothing aggressive you will be
surprised it's kind of a different
recipe it's a little bit more healthy
and I think it will be fun to try
something different
okay